today for us is a grief of pain as we  mark eight years since the horrific  attack in Tucson every one of our  colleagues knows exactly where he or she  was when we heard the news of what was  happening here some of the news was  confusing all of it was saddening I  myself was at a synagogue for a bat  mitzvah and but again every one can tell  you the story as through any crowd that  we were in or any group who were in any  place that we were just the horror of it  all came through on that day gun  violence shattered lives in Arizona and  tragedy pierced America's heart we were  blessed to be with survivors of that  attack and survivors of so many other  gun acts of gun violence today but today  is also a day of action we say enough is  enough by finally bringing common-sense  bipartisan background check legislation  to the floor of the house